a beautiful young woman arrived on our
theater screens last year he is now
about to arrive in your living room here
is the lovely and talented Rachel Ward
and the deeply disturbed Chevy Chase
the Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences has several branches but among
them only one is at once both artist and
scientist the cinematographer and the
winner for tonight's Best Picture just
kidding that's the cameraman folks for
you at home and he or she these days
must have a working knowledge of optics
chemistry math mechanics engineering and
human anatomy each and an exact and
demanding discipline in itself the
application of those Sciences to the
composition texture a mood of the film
demands nothing less than art in
addition to all that the cinematographer
must have another talent the ability to
get work the artistic scientist
nominated by their peers are Alex
Thompson for Excalibur
Billy Williams four on Golden Pond
Miroslav on reject the rad comb
Douglas Slocum for Raiders of the Lost
Ark victorious to our four legs
those are the men behind the cameras and
now for the name behind the seal Rachel
and the winner is Vittorio Storaro
Red's was one of the most international
picture their work with the crew was
formed by people came from United States
from England from Finland from Spain
from Italy and I think was one of the
best crew they work with Warren thank
you to call me to be part of this crew
thank you very much
for her uh many rules that have
established her prominence in the cinema
encyclopedia here is truly a luminous
star to be presented with an honorary
award to make the presentation here as a
young star I was about to write his own
chapter in that encyclopedia John
Travolta